my next guest is calling for judges to
be dispatched to the border to hammer
out Asylum cases in days not years Texas
Republican Congressman T Tony Gonzalez
joining me now so thank you for being
here happy New Year but why do you want
more judges on the border because
President Biden is calling for more
money to process migrants
faster oh thank thank you Edward for
having me on there is no amount of money
that will get us out of this crisis it's
simply about enforcing the laws that are
on the books and you do that by surging
immigration judges to the Border people
get their cases heard in days not years
nine out of 10 people will not qualify
for Asylum because they're fleeing
economic persecution they're not fleeing
political or religious persecution and
those nine out of 10 people should
immediately be deported just like
President Trump did just like President
Obama did and other presidents as well
you do those things and that signals to
the world that our border is closed
anything else is is nothing but window
dressing I sat down with President uh me
the Mexican president Lopez oor several
months ago we had a six-hour discussion
followed by followed by a two-hour lunch
you know the the the Secretary of State
and DHS DHS secretary going down to
Mexico and having a two-hour discussion
tells me it's probably it's a good start
but it's a long way before we get any
real tangible results out of it yeah we
also know the mexic president is long
winded he's known for that I don't have
to tell you this but since President Joe
Biden came into office 7.1 million
people have crossed into the US
illegally that's more uh people than the
population of 35 States that's 70% of
the states in the US why do you think
that this alone has not forc President
Biden to
act well this is what they want in many
cases this this in many cases they view
this as a policy win they they
absolutely want what is occurring but
the rest of America does is not and
that's the part that they're they're at
this inass and I worry what does 2024
look like but fast forward 3 years from
now we're on a pace that is
unsustainable by all means I I'd also
say too you know this isn't just the
White House Congress has a role to play
next week I will be hosting speaker
Johnson and over 60 of my Republican
colleagues we will be in Eagle Pass we
will be on the border we will be having
discussions with firstline uh leaders
people that are seeing every single day
and it's important for Congress to not
just talk about the things but actually
hold the administration accountable yeah
and on that meeting the the house
speaker is expected to ask for executive
action by the president uh what do you
want to see uh out of that uh you know
news conference the pressure that you're
trying to put
on I I I simply want the administration
to do their job that's it you know
secretary blinkin going to Mexico City
that was him doing his job that that's
the role of the Secretary of State and
you know we live in a world where there
are particip participation Awards I'm
there you go I'm happy to to give you a
pat on the back I need them to just
enforce the laws that are already in the
books and they also need to understand
that the power of the purse is very real
I sit on the House Appropriations
Committee and there will be no funding
until until some of these meaningful
border Solutions come together I get it
we're not going to get everything we
want the House pass hr2 that is a
starting point but I am looking for real
tangible solutions that can not only
help secure our border but keep
Americans safe there is a real threat in
this country and all Americans to
deserve to be safe whether you're
Democrat Republican or don't vote at all
right representative Tony Gonzalez from
Texas I appreciate it you know the
problem firsthand thank you for joining
us here and happy New Year thank you
Edward I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analys
is